♪ ♪
>> Dana: MAYOR PETE BUTTIGIEG
FACING ANGRY CONSTITUENTS IN
SOUTH BEND WHILE TAKING A BREAK
FROM THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
HE HELD A TOWN HALL WHERE HE
CAME UNDER INTENSE SCRUTINY FROM
RESIDENTS WHO BLAMED HIM FOR NOT
BEING PRESENT ENOUGH AFTER THE
DEADLY SHOOTING OF A BLACK MAN
BY A WHITE POLICE OFFICER.
>> SURE.
IF EVERYONE -- WE ARE GOING TO
ALLOW HIM TO SPEAK.
IF EVERYONE CAN JUST CALM DOWN.
>> Dana: WE KNOW THE DEBATES
ARE COMING UP THIS WEEK.
SOMEWHAT DIFFICULT, IF YOU
ALREADY HAVE A JOB, IF YOU ARE A
GOVERNOR OR MAYOR WHERE YOU ARE
IN CHARGE OF THINGS TO ALSO RUN
FOR PRESIDENT OF THE SAME TIME.
EVERYONE IS GOING TO SAVE BEN
AWAY.
IT'S ALL YOUR FAULT.
THESE GUYS, IF YOUR MAYOR, YOU
NEED FACE-TO-FACE CONTACT WITH
PEOPLE.
UNLIKE IF YOU'RE IN WASHINGTON.
>> Greg: IT'S SO FUNNY TO
BECAUSE THIS APPLIES MORE TO
MAYOR de BLASIO THAN THE THIS
GUY BECAUSE de BLASIO IS FAR
WORSE MAYOR THAN MAYOR PETE.
EVERYONE IS DOING A SEGMENT ON
MAYOR PETE.
SOME GUY ALMOST NOBODY KNEW FOR
MONTHS AGO AND THAT'S THE CURSE
OF THE SPOTLIGHT.
THE SPOTLIGHT CUTS BOTH WAYS.
HE WAS PROBABLY THINKING IN HIS
HEAD, YOU KNOW WHAT, I'M NOT
GOING TO END UP BEING THE
NOMINEE BUT THIS GOING TO BE
GOOD FOR ME LATER BECAUSE MY
FACE WILL BE -- I'LL BE ON THE
DEBATES AND EVERYONE WILL THINK
I'M AWESOME BUT THEN PEOPLE FIND
OUT YOU CAN'T EVEN RUN YOUR
CITY.
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO RUN A
COUNTRY?
IT'S REALLY HARD AND THAT KIND
OF SITUATION TO REMAIN CALM WHEN
YOU ARE FACED WITH AN EMOTIONAL
SITUATION.
LOOKING DOWN AT YOUR NOTES AND
SAYING, YOU KNOW, I DIDN'T ASK
YOU TO VOTE FOR ME.
HE CAME OFF AS AS A REALLY SMALL
CANDIDATE.
WHAT IS PRESIDENTIAL?
I HATE TO SAY PRESIDENTIAL.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dana: THERE IS A CITY
COUNCILMAN NAMED OLIVER DAVIS,
THE LONGEST-SERVING BLACK MEMBER
OF THE COUNCIL, HE HAS BASICALLY
SAID HE APPRECIATES THAT HE WAS
THERE AND HE SAID VERY FEW
PEOPLE COULD HAVE WITHSTOOD WHAT
HE WENT THROUGH WITHOUT
COMPLETELY LOSING IT.
DO YOU THINK MAYOR PETE SHOULD
NOT GO TO THE DEBATES THIS WEEK
AND FOCUS ON HIS JOB AS MAYOR OR
GO TO THE DEBATE AND FACE THE
POSSIBLE BACKLASH FROM PEOPLE
SAYING THAT HE SHOULD BE AT HOME
WORKING ON THE ISSUE.
>> Juan: I THINK HE SHOULD GO
TO THE DEBATE.
HE'S RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
BUDDIES GOT TO BE ABLE TO HANDLE
BOTH AT ONE TIME.
THIS IS THE REALITY OF A GUY
WHO'S A SMALL TOWN MAYOR.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE ABLE TO DEAL
WITH CRISIS BECAUSE ON THE
NATIONAL LEVEL, YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO DEAL WITH PEOPLE WHO
REALLY ARE ANGRY AT YOU AND
SCREAMING THEY BE THREATENING IN
A WAY THAT --
>> Dana: I THINK AS MAYOR, YOU
SEE PEOPLE MORE FACE-TO-FACE.
>> Juan: THE GUY THAT YOU
CITED, THEY LONGEST-SERVING
MEMBER OF THE COUNCIL IN
SOUTH BEND SAID THAT HE NOT ONLY
TALKED TO THE PRESS BEFORE HE
TALKED TO THE FAMILY.
HE THEN WENT ON TO NOT ATTEND A
VIGIL WHERE YOU COULD GET
FACE-TO-FACE AND LET PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND WE ARE COMING FROM.
HE HAS NEVER EXPLAINED WHY THE
BODY CAM ON THE POLICE OFFICER
DIDN'T WORK.
>> Dana: WASN'T TURNED ON.
>> Juan: I DON'T KNOW.
SAID DIDN'T WORK.
YOU SEE A DECLINE IN TERMS OF
THE PERCENTAGE OF BLACK PEOPLE
ON THE POLICE FORCE DURING HIS
TERM AND HE FIRED THE BLACK
POLICE CHIEF.
THERE IS A LOT GOING ON HERE
THAT'S KIND OF INVENTED.
MAYBE IT'S THE HISTORY THAT
SMELL COME TO BITE HIM.
>> Dana: BASICALLY A ONE-TWO
PUNCH.
THERE'S THE LOSS OF LIFE AND
THEN THE COMMUNITIES FRUSTRATION
AND THE QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED.
ALSO IT'S AN AREA WHERE HE IS
ALREADY POLITICALLY WEAK.
>> Jesse: HE CAN'T AFFORD TO
LOSE BLACK SUPPORT.
HE IS CLOSE TO ZERO THIS IS
REALLY GOING TO HURT HIM.
HE HANDLED IT POORLY.
AS JUAN SAID, HE SKIPPED THE
VIGIL, CALLED THE MEANIE OF THE
HOARY TALK TO THE FAMILY.
THE
TO HAVE HIM ON A LECTERN,
DETACHED, MOTIONLESS, NOT
RESPONDING PASSIONATELY TO THE
ANGER AND PAIN FROM HIS OWN
COMMUNITY WAS AWFUL.
HE NEEDS TO GET OUT ON THE
STREETS.
HE NEEDS TO GET INTO
NEIGHBORHOODS.
HE NEEDS TO HUG PEOPLE AND SEE
THEIR TEARS AND RESPOND AND
IMMERSE HIMSELF IN THE ENGLISH.
THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY HERE.
HE NEEDS TO NATIONALIZE THIS
ISSUE IF HE WANTS ANY HOPE FOR A
REBOUNDING FROM THIS.
HE NEEDS TO MAKE IT A CORE
ISSUE.
HE NEEDS TO TALK ABOUT IT AT THE
DEBATE AND THAT'S THE ONLY SHOT
HE HAS.
HE DID HANDLE A FEW THINGS WELL.
TALKING ABOUT BRINGING THE DOJ
AND, APPOINTING AN INDEPENDENT
PROSECUTOR.
HE'S TAKEN A LITTLE OWNERSHIP OF
IT BUT IT'S A MURKY SITUATION
BECAUSE OF THE BODY CAM ON THE
FACT THAT THE VICTIM'S BODY WAS
TRANSPORTED NOT BY AN AMBULANCE
BY A POLICE VEHICLE.
AT THE SAME TIME, THE GUY
ALLEGEDLY THREW A KNIFE AT THE
OFFICER, WAS RUMMAGING AROUND
CARS, AND HAS A RAP SHEET WITH
WEAPONS AND COCAINE CHARGES.
YOU DON'T REALLY KNOW WHAT THE
TRUTH WAS.
>> Lisa: YOU HAD MENTIONED
AFRICAN-AMERICAN VOTERS AND
THAT'S PARTICULARLY TROUBLING
FOR THEM IF YOU LOOK AT STATES
LIKE SOUTH CAROLINA WHERE BLACK
VOTERS MAKE UP ABOUT 60% OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY VOTES.
IT'S GOING TO BE A BIG CHALLENGE
FOR HIM.
IF YOU'RE USING AS YOUR MAIL
RECORD A LAUNCHPAD, THE
RECORD COMES UNDER SCRUTINY IN
YOUR CALLED OUT FOR NOT BEING
STRONG, WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO RUN
ON?
IT'S GOING TO BE THE CHALLENGE.
THERE'S NO REASONING WITH AN
ANGRY MOB.
WHEN PEOPLE ARE UPSET, THEY ARE
YELLING IN EMOTIONS ARE HIGH,
HE'S TRYING TO REASON.
THERE'S NO REASONING.
THAT'S ALSO A CHALLENGE, TRYING
TO TALK TO SOME PEOPLE BECAUSE
THEY'RE ANGRY.
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK THAT
WAS A MAMA.
THEY WERE -- THEY WEREN'T
ATTACKING ANYBODY.
STEVE I WANT PEOPLE ARE
SCREAMING AT YOU.
>> Dana: LOCAL POLITICS IS
SOME OF THE HARDEST POLITICS.
ALL POLITICS IS LOCAL.
THERE YOU HAVE IT.
>> Greg: JUAN BROUGHT UP
BIDEN.
ED RENDELL SAID THIS COULD BE A
GENERATIONAL THING.
IT'S NOT JUST OLD GUYS LIKE
BIDEN FACING THE ACCUSATION OF